mag
ich musste etwas sagen dass du dich hast
und du nicht weißt du nicht bei mir zu
entschuldigen also ich oder dass du
deinen komischen typen wendig zum teufel
gejagt ist und mir recht gibst dich so
klug bin und es die von anfang an gesagt
habe ich habe wenn schon wieder nicht
getroffen
aber diesmal war es meine schuld ich
habe nicht gewusst dass es verschiedene
ausgänge bei den u bahn haltestellen
gibt und da hab ich ja ja ich hab's
vermasselt okay und dann war ich ganz
durcheinander und ganz traurig und
deswegen habe ich nicht aufgepasst mag
ich habe noch etwas ganz anderes format
nun spricht schon so schlimm kann es
nicht sein
ich habe dein tag sie vermasselt war es
ein taxi kann man nicht vermasseln
sondern höchstens ein taxi was hast du
gemacht ich bin hineingefahren
ich habe aber es ist nicht so schlimm es
hat nur ein gebäude oder ein kratzer an
der seite und praxis in mattsies
verkaufs und verbeult was soll ich
meinem chef sagen unterversicherung ja
aber das fahrrad hat das nicht so gut
überstanden
einmal zu rechnen also müssen wir doch
gesagt dass im iran fahrrad gerne leid
und dann muss ich ihn ja auch sagen dass
ich es kaputt gemacht habe sagen wir so
er weiß gar nicht das hat ihr sein
fahrrad gedient hat aber du hast doch
gesagt ich soll das ich habe gedacht er
merkt es nicht